what's next for you just kind of try to
keep a hold on the job in center and uh
be a leader for the guys
on defense
as a rookie you're just trying to
survive you know your first your first
part of the season is like i want to
prove i
belong here don't feel like you got to
go out and prove
anything to anybody because when you
feel like you got to start trying to
prove stuff to people or show people
that's when stuff starts going the wrong
way my first time up
it's you know you're trying to get the
nerves out and all that kind of stuff
my first time up didn't really go too
well
uh that's when i realized that the grass
at wrigley field
will heat up any kind of ground ball i
don't know if it's still doing it right
now
but if you get a chance man don't hit
the ball on the ground at wrigley bro
because
it will beat me up nah damn you guys are
talking about this so as pitchers
you don't get to i make an error i get a
chance to hit
you guys give up a big hit in the
situation
manager pulls you out fans letting you
have it cameras on you all the way to
the dugout you don't get a chance to
hide
so when you lose that confidence and
i'll start with you doc it's
inside of you where do you go to get
that back what do you do or how do you
get out of your own way
this time remember my first big lease i
was in houston that my parents was there
they're the parents they came over from
florida to watch dwight gooden in his
big league debut
after the game and then say son what do
you think i said well [ __ ] won a lot of
games
my next star was at wrigley field they
got knocked down in the second inning i
gave like eight
runs that called what do you think now
first time you go through something like
that it's a wake-up call
once you get out there just say the
first thing i'm getting a couple hits
early
then i'll start thinking oh man here we
go again if i started thinking away
then all right here we go again but i
said okay let me just make
quality pictures don't try to make a
perfect fish just make a quality pick
and at that point when i had a bad game
or whatever i had to understand that
the fans if they happen to be or write
something bad it's about my performance
understanding me
me
it helped me in the long run you know
like years two years three
i was able to okay i've been there
before let me just put that aside let me
get back to where i do best
and go from there devin let's be honest
guys get jealous you're having a success
and okay young phil it's not gonna
always be this easy and guess what
they're right
how were you accepted in the clubhouse i
mean we have a great group of guys so it
was
it was nothing but love from everyone
and i mean it was just a good support
system for me to have especially being a
rookie
you know there were times where i didn't
feel like i was throwing that well
and it was a week or two that i just
didn't feel like me on the mound and
like everyone
that i talked to just you know they were
super encouraging because they all
wanted to see me do well also
then comes kyle lewis i enjoy watching
you play what you do where you go about
your game
and you're a game team going forward
one rook of the year that's enough
pressure but what's next for you
just kind of try to keep a hold on the
job in the center and
be a leader for the guys on defense and
uh you know then at the plate just
trying to have a simple approach
trust what i can do bring some
confidence to the game and bring some
confidence to the team when i come to
the plate
i try to embody that and try to try to
be a leader in that way
i'm glad you said that because going
forward
that's what you're going to have to do
day after day people are going to look
up to you
as a rookie with this energy you won
this award now
you're one of the leaders on the team
grow on that
that's not pressure that's something you
embrace i saw ryan embrace it he
inspired me
understand that you will inspire your
teammates guys that have been around
trying to figure out how to get through
it to see you have that success
you will continue to inspire them to be
better themselves
like he said man just continue to
inspire each other your teammates
just do what you do like don't feel like
you got to go above and beyond
just do what god gave you and you're
going to be all right and great things
will happen man
great things to happen